This hyperbola is centered at 0,0. It has an a value of 3 and a b value of
positive 5. Nice work if you got these correct. Now, let's check your graph.
We'll start with an ellipse. So, this ellipse will be centered at the origin
and will go 3 units in the x direction. And 5 units in the y direction. We'll
draw a dashed box around our ellipse, so that way we can start to draw a
hyperbola. Next, we'll draw in our two diagonals across our rectangle. We want
to extend these along the graph, so that way we can draw in our hyperbola
branches. So now we're ready to cut the ellipse open. We turn each of the
pieces out. And then we can see we have our hyperbola. And notice again, that
we can get our rectangle, just by looking at the a value and the b value. We
start with the origin and we move 3 units in the x direction for a and 5 units
in the y direction for b. This hyperbola opens to the left and to the right
since the x squared term comes first. Whichever term is positive, the x squared
term or the y squared term. That will determine which way our hyperbola opens.
Since the x squared term here is positive, then we know that it opens left and
right.